another Academy Award winner returns to
present another Academy Award Geena
Davis
Alfred Hitchcock once said movies our
life with the boring parts cut out I
can't think of a better description for
what an editor does she or sometimes he
must take as many as 100 hours of film
and find the two hours that make us
laugh cry shudder and fright and sigh
and ecstasy as an actor I really
appreciate their work and right about
now some of you watching are probably
thinking pretty fondly of editors too of
course the show is live so we can't take
advantage of their skills but maybe I
can help you don't realize it but I just
cut four and a half minutes out of this
show the nominees for best achievement
in film editing are Dennis burglar David
Finn fir Dean goodhill Don Brochu
Richard Nord and dung Koenig for the
fugitives
anvi coats for in the line of fire gerry
hambling for in the name of the Father
Veronica unit for the piano Michael Kahn
for cymbals list
and the Oscar goes to Michael Kahn for
singular
I want to thank the Academy for Audrey
Schindler's List with this wonderful
award it's been an extraordinary year
the process was painful but the result
was glorious
it was list has become an international
event that that is enriched all our
lives
I want to thank you Stephen for the most
fulfilling time of my life and I'm so
grateful to you for sharing with me this
remarkable gift thanks chickie for your
constant encouragement and produces
Jerry and Bronco for your help and to my
terrific editing team Hallam Pat Michael
and Peter for your strength and loyalty
and Adam Adam and Alison I love you good
night thank you everybody